what I'm going to talk about is a
project called actually some kind of a
side project called the things detector
that's something that I did a couple of
months after the hackathon in the run
and i attended a bit about myself my
name is Zach I mainly do data science
consultant around front fraud prevention
areas or FinTech in general but that's
not why we're here we're here to to talk
about the same science detector so the
first and probably the most important
thing here is to remember that it was a
purely educational and something I just
did for fun I actually actually I took
the androids core patty course the CS
231 it's actually a pretty good one
and I wanted to do something with a
$500.00 that I had on GCP credit so like
buying some GPUs and trying to run and a
neural network was something that I I
thought it would be fun and all the
episodes that I already had from The
Simpsons were just a pretty cool data
set so what we're going to do is we are
trying to to classify a single frame
okay not a full episode just a single
frame and just output a vector of one
hot in one hot encoded vector story of
which character was was in the image
only for the four main characters ok
we'll we'll keep it easy I thought it is
going to be something like a weekend or
two eventually went out to be a bit more
but that's why I chose only four
characters and then and and working only
on the image and not on the video itself
although there are pretty pretty nice
deep learning ways to deal with
sequences so that's basically what we're
trying to do and then I'll just show an
example now of how the real output looks
like the real output takes a full
episode and just samples some of the
friends and generates something like
we'll see now it's a tagged video
we saw your heart but Ernie is not going
to feel as good as you think just know
them I am very very sorry okay so you
can see the characters on the bottom
alternating and now we can see actually
a false prediction
Bart is appeared although he's not in
the image okay so basically the final
output of everything will be a full
episode that looks like this the episode
on top and then on the bottom you can
just see which character is currently a
turn since we're in Python and not in
any kind of deep learning or machine
learning talk I'm and we only have 30
minutes I don't have a lot of time to
get into how exactly the network is
built and the architecture and I must
say it's probably not the the very
interesting part of it it's a fairly
simple network build on top of vgg we'll
talk a little bit about something that
has some Python relevance of how do we
implement that we'd Kerris that that was
the the packet that I chose to use but
just so we'll all be on the same line
I'll give a short very short intro for
CNN CNN stands for a convolutional
neural networks and we'll treat it today
as some kind of a black box
the important thing to remember are that
it it's somehow magically learns a
couple of filters okay and here we
already see the learned features filters
I'm sorry and then we also learn some
weights that that combine or take some
some of the activations of the filters
and actually move them to be whatever
output we want I wanted a vector of four
indices whichever one of them is the
probability to see Bart Homer Lisa and
Marge
okay so generally if everything went
well and if the training went well what
I would expect is to first to learn
filters that are meaningful for my
problem so here we can see that we
somehow learn the March Hare and March
eyes and Bart's hair which are probably
indicative and then I would also expect
the way to actually say something like P
Marge would be sorry would be hi if we
saw those two filters and P Lisa would
be hi if we got if we found in the image
one of these okay that's like in in less
than a minute I hope some general
overview or overview about what a CNN is
and probably the important things that
we need to know for for today stop so if
I take Alicia and her dragons
I would probably expect if my network is
good to get a vector of zeros okay more
or less because neither of the
characters are really in the image and
if I take this image which is basically
a Marge and Lisa I want to get something
like zero for bar zero for Homer and
something around one for the two other
cartels that's the only deep learning
stuff we are going to do today the rest
will be some Python code and some really
nice thing that I had to do in order to
generate the training set but first
we'll talk about transfer learning so
that's a call and that's a concept it
happens in a lot of problems not only in
deep learning that we sometimes just
don't have enough data to learn or to
study everything from scratch and what
we actually want to do is we want to
have a jump start to start with
something that someone already learned
maybe on a different data but something
similar and try to see how we can take
something and then maybe just find you
in or just learn some other few layers
which are possible with a limited amount
of data that we have so I started with
vgg vgg again we're not talking any any
deep learning deep stuff but vdg the
probably very common architecture for
image processing and it's a fairly
simple one so it's pretty easy to choose
what exactly do we want to do with it
the input of moojiji
is an image as you can see here and then
it goes through several a
several CNN layers it does some stuff at
the at the middle and at the end what it
does is it outputs a vector of a
thousand categories okay that was the
problem that VG was trained on
it's called imagenet but doesn't really
matter I'm not interesting in the
thousand categories I'm not interesting
if a cat or a dog or a house or sheep or
whatever was in the image but maybe
something that it learned here and took
weeks to train would be useful for me
even though I'm only looking on Simpsons
and a cartoon and it's not a real image
and all everything probably these layers
would still remain the same or at least
be beneficial and save me some time so
my model we will take vgg actually a pre
trained version of vgg and and i have a
hyper parameter inside that can allow me
to choose where do I want to hook my
model in do I want to take this output
or this output or this and that I tried
many actually the last one was the best
like taking as much as I can from vgg
what's the best and we'll see an example
of how how can we do it pretty easily
with karyn's I don't know if you can
really read the code so I'll try to go
over it basically if you've used carrots
before you probably know about the
create model concept that's that's a
function that we that we need to
implement that basically builds our
whole are all model building a model in
carrots is something like this we are
basically using layers and other
components that carrots already give us
and what I also used is the carrot
application vgg which is the pre trained
and pre-built vgg model so what am I
doing here we have the input side ok the
input and sorry which is of unknown
input size but that doesn't really make
a difference okay we have some tensor
some math some I don't know placeholder
to hold the input then I'm building the
vgg model that's something that carrots
does automatically for me it comes with
carrots you don't really need to do
anything and then I'm building another
model which will take vgg input which is
this the image okay and its output would
be the layer that I chose to hook in
okay so now I have a sub vgg model
something that will just take the part
that I'm interesting in from vgg and
that would be the output
okay so X here is actually applying the
base model over the over my input then
I'm actually getting the diversion of VG
that I wanted the the output layer of
vegetated I wanted and then I can just
continue building the rest of my network
like I would do with any other model I
didn't build anything dramatic here so
we're not going to spend some time on
that and I think that's it we compiled
the model return it and that's our
create model so transfer learning from
any other model any other trained model
and Kara's already comes with pretty
much quite a lot of applications it's
pretty easy pretty straightforward and I
just saved myself probably a couple of
weeks of training because someone has
already trained vgd and and and all the
weights are are meaningful even for my
problem second problem is that like with
any other deep learning network we need
quite a lot of data to train it and a
data in my case is an image a full image
and the labels in my case would be the
one hot encoded vectors okay so I need
quite a lot of images extracting them
extracting the images from the videos
it's not a really hard problem it's
actually pretty easy I could it could
easily get thousands of them but tagging
the images are a really hard problem I
couldn't do it in any way other than
sending it to a crowdsourcing platform
or something like Mechanical Turk or I
actually use heat intelligence
to give a human the the task of actually
a check boxing which which character
appeared there and that's expensive
like I I paid a couple of I think it was
$15 or $20 for a couple of the Filipinos
Indians Chinese or whoever uses those
platforms to to actually talk some of my
images but that was only did it for
testing because I
I only had a couple of hundreds of them
and that's fairly good for testing
that's nothing for training I need to
find a way for four for generating a lot
of images really a lot of them and I
don't know naturally I thought let's
let's use Google Images because if I go
to Google and I search for Bart Simpson
I would probably get a lot and I do get
a lot of images the problem is that most
of them looks like this this is actually
a real screenshot from man from Google
Images and that's what happens when you
search for Maggie and these are not
perfect images to to learn from like
this is crap this is nonsense that this
doesn't really look like Barton in a
real and a real image and obviously
Maggie is even worse eventually what I
did is I ran a search for all main
characters actually for every character
I knew about okay yeah containing Moe
and then I load the other and manually
selected only the clean images that took
me like an hour but an hour of my time
is it's probably fair and I only took
images that I can easily separate the
background from so I wouldn't take
anything that comes from a real scene of
all of the simpsons because I couldn't
really take automatically crop only the
image but if we if we had something like
this image for example or that one I
think OpenCV could easily just take the
background out and eventually I got
something like this so that's basically
my training set I have a lot of images
for every tour after and I already
cropped all only they only the character
I already resize them all to 300 and 300
pixels and eventually I got something
between fifty two hundred and fifty
images per character but that's not a
real training set because I cannot train
my network with that that doesn't look
like a real frame from from a simpsons
åkesson so what I really need to do is
to take my my I don't know let's call it
the three training set and build or
generate a real training image okay so
what I'm doing here is basically my
algorithm was to take a random
background
and I detected backgrounds by actually
sampled a lot of friends for many
episodes and took only friends that did
not contain a lot of pixels that are
close to the Simpsons yellow picture
which is a very very unique one and then
I got a lot of friends like this okay so
in my experiment I had something like a
couple of hundreds of a pool of a couple
of hundreds of black ones to choose from
then in every iteration of the generator
I choose how many characters do I want
to have in the specific frame in this
example it's two and I chose Bart and
Homer I could also chose the character
the meta character called others which
is just a lot of images of all the other
characters okay it's actually very
important to add that one I wouldn't
really get into that but basically if I
don't do that then the network would
learn that yellow color is everything is
everyone it would just hit one for
everyone okay so I need to add a lot of
images that are yellow but are not Bart
Homer marginalism
and then once I wanted show once I
choose the actual limit I scale it
rotate it flippy do whatever I want with
it and just randomly place it on the on
the background that way I can generate I
can actually generate endless amount of
of Simpsons same some Springs and
looking for Looking Backward I can
actually say that I think 90% of of my
time on this project was writing and and
then making the generator better because
if the generator generates something
that is it doesn't really look like a
real frame then you'll have problems
learning later actually you know
actually you will learn but you will
have problems applying that for for a
real real image so these are actual
examples for for training set images
okay that was actually generated by by
the generator and you can see that it's
not always it doesn't always make sense
like for example this one homer and Lisa
are kind of floating in the air and are
cut in an unreal way but I don't really
care it looks more or less like a frame
from Simpsons and my network would
probably learn that
pretty well okay this code that's a bit
more code again I'll just briefly go
over it and know that you probably
cannot see it but the way to do that
would Karis is to use the feed generator
method that every model has some we can
actually instead of instead of learning
with feet which would take an x and y
static X&Y just iterate another feed
generator would use a generator that
that I give it and my generator needs to
heal x and y at the end and then I'm
free to do whatever I want I'm free to
take my training set and just run them
more and more images as my network needs
and actually using internally the care
of image data generator the chaos comes
with a built-in image that a generator
that takes care of rotating and flipping
and scaling and stuff like this
I needed that but that was not enough so
I use it internally I basically do while
true I take the batches ok the eggs the
eggs okay I for every iteration I do
around the permutation just so we will
get random results and then I work in
batches of I think it was 32 again some
kind of a hyper parameter in my network
and for every batch I generate an array
of zeros that will hold all the images
and then I just go over and terrain and
generate another one and another one
from the same X&Y batches okay that's
the process that gives me at every
iteration 32 images and 32 output
vectors and that's what I yield at the
end if you really want
I hope this code is not the real code I
kind of cut a lot of stuff from it if
you want to see the real code from this
for this and for the other for the other
code there is a link at the end for the
original blog post this whole talk is
based on some kind of a blog post that I
wrote about the Simpsons detector and
then you can have first some many more
interesting issues and then the link to
github and to everything can have the
data in the code and run it yourself or
I don't know do whatever you want okay
next we're going to see some examples
like normally when I give this talk then
we talked a little bit about CNN and
what what our weaknesses and what
network might not have learned well we
didn't do it here but still I'll say
that remember that we we learned from
Google Images and Google Images most
images are face front so we normally
don't get to see or the network didn't
really get to see homer for example from
the back or from the side or something
like this and we will see that that's a
major problem let's begin with some with
some false false predictions again in
the blog post I have a longer video it's
about eight minutes with a lot of
examples here I only picked like a two
or three for every for every category
what we're gonna see here are that first
we have a problem with scenes with many
characters like if we have a lot of
yellow in the image it will probably
start predicting everyone and it's gonna
be a real mess and when and only ones we
get back to an image with the only know
one character or two is where we are
going to see the more accurate result
personally I believe that that's because
I only chose two to generate a lot of
training images with one two and three
cartoons okay so that's kind of a
problem and small characters are
obviously a problem if the character is
very very small we would probably
wouldn't detect it and again it was
another parameter in my training process
to choose how much do I want to scale
the damages okay in characters that
don't face the camera you'll see it in
the end the third in the third frame
there is that's an example for multiple
characters in the scene
so like me to save the town we you could
come to know you do that here we have a
lot of problems actually that's a pretty
bad scene I guess the dark and and weird
background has also something to do with
that the network performs better on on
background like the outside background
or outdoors or something like this you
can see it when they were very very
small we didn't detect anything and only
now we start detecting something look at
Homer now look at when Homer looks to
the sides okay you can really you can
actually see in flicker in the in the
bottom bar and also we don't detect Bart
you okay so three examples for false
predictions for actually the main
problems that I kind of expected to have
because I'm only I'm only learning from
Google images who battery is very low 7%
let's let's hope that we can make it the
next video would be some nice catches
actually catches it that didn't really
expect the model to to catch okay that's
a pretty nice one we could see all of
them and it was that's really good this
is look at their hair now okay Bart
snare it's probably a pretty strong
indicator for Bart and even if it's not
here we could still pick him I have no
idea how it detected Bart and Homer here
not here but here
well I actually just put the last one
for the music for the publicist playing
yeah basically that's it if you have any
questions I'll be more than happy to
take one that's the the link for the
original blog post and the QR codes cure
code also well it's there so that's only
if you have like 15 minutes and you
really want to read about some other
cool stuff that was there and basically
that's it questions mmm no not really
okay so the question was how much time
does it take to do the inference part
like to actually run the model and get
the result I couldn't really do it on
real time like that was my dream my
dream was to have a web page where you
could actually drag and drop your
Simpsons episode and it would just play
it a number on the bottom do the magic
trick with the with the characters I
couldn't really run it in front end like
on the browser mainly because the model
is pretty pretty heavy and then because
it just takes more time than than the
running time so what I'm doing is I have
my own class that generates the the full
video and exports it as a video it takes
me around I don't know maybe two or
three minutes let's say tops five
minutes or something like this to
generate something for for a fool I
autism I think yes okay so if again the
question was about the training size and
if I remember correctly but I'm not
really sure here it was around 50,000
images something like this that were
generated with the generator and then
went into the network yeah so about the
transfer learning it seemed weird for me
as well like I didn't really expect that
the
a very good transfer learning from
imagenet like the the vgg was trained on
imagenet which productive you know it's
it's a set of real images like camera
taken images and what I'm running
through is cartoons which are not really
the same that's why I thought I would
have to play with that a lot and I build
my code so I can choose the the hook in
point eventually the last one was the
best I really don't know why but it just
worked so vigie vigie is the
architecture and it was trained on a
data set called image now that's a lot
of images I don't really remember how
many but the output is one of I think
thousand categories okay so a category
there would be a cat a dog house
something like this but again when I did
the transfer learning I only took the
first the first convolutional layers I
didn't really take the weights part okay
so when they learn which patches are
relevant for dogs I didn't take those
weights
I just cropped the network at that part
and I only took the convolutional
features and then I added my own layers
that learned Homer Marge Li signboard
okay I think I think we're done thanks